- [Glo$ik] Hey, Hey.
Okay. We in the club
(women screaming)
(upbeat music)
- [Director] We brought
together seven drunk people.
- I am drunk.
- I'm drunk.
- I am very drunk right now.
- I am very drunk.
- [Director] One of them is sober.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they will split a cash price.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire price.
Who is the odd one out.
(glasses clinking)
- [Kelly] Cheers to new friends.
and new experiences.
- And happy dads, we've got
to cheers to happy dads.
- [All] Happy dads?
- Yes happy dads.
- [Glo$ik] Champagne popping over here.
- Bryce you and I are going to be boys.
- Louie, I know your name.
I know your name, Louie.
- Bryce we're boys until the end.
- I'm with you.
- Until the end.
- I believe you.
- Questions, what did everybody drink?
- No, no, no, no, no.
Let's just smell each other's breaths.
- [Jenn] Smell each others breaths?
- I don't wanna smell anybody.
- I'm down, I'm down to smell.
- It's like, why are
you trying to smell me?
This is weird.
Like, I don't know what
you do in your free time.
I don't go smell people, like what?
- Can I just smell your breath?
- Okay.
- Go ahead.
(exaggerated exhale)
That actually smell pretty
good, you smell like.
- [Louie] Can I smell yours?
- Okay.
- May I?
- Yeah, go for it.
- God that's hard.
Can I smell?
- [Nizzy] What if he's like,
"I can't smell anything".
- Why are you directing us?
- I'm not directing, I just want to smell.
I'm the king of smells,
I'm kind of a hound dog.
- Hey, the sober one leads the way, right?
- [Hamel] Right
- Question what did
everyone drink before this?
Go, we'll go on a line.
- I went to brunch.
I had two and a half miosis
and then I have four shots
and then I drank some
of my handle of tequila.
- Okay.
- Four?
- Girl I'm Irish.
- I had a bottle of Ciroc, I'm bougie.
It was a new special edition pomegranate
and I got lit.
- How much did you have?
- [Glo$ik] How much?
Half of the bottle.
- I went to Trader
Joe's right before this.
- [Glo$ik] Oh, you do look
like a Trader Joe's fan.
- I bought their tequila,
and I drank half the bottle as well.
- Well, I'm a representative of happy dad.
You know the heard seltzer.
- I don't know what that is.
- [Jenn ] No.
- [Glo$ik] What is happy dad?
- That's the best hard
(beep) seltzer on earth.
- Give us an ad right now.
- What did you drink?
What did you drink?
- I, literally had just happy dad.
That's my seltzer that's my brand.
- [Nizzy] He's drinking his brand.
He's drinking his brand.
- He's he always trying to promote.
- He kept on like promoting his brand
his alcohol brand, or drinking brand.
- Because it's literally
the best seltzer on earth.
Like, its better than White Claw.
It's better than anything else.
- My cousin got me this
half a bottle of tequila.
- Wait where are you
from, where's the accent?
- I'm from London.
- [Bryce] London.
- [Nizzy] Oh I love that.
(all excitedly talking about London)
- [Hemal] I would gladly
swap accents with you.
You guys have got a cool accent.
- He could be low key
like the British Hitler.
You know what I mean?
He could be.
- [Glo$ik] He had, I
can see in your cheeks.
You definitely have.
- You can see it right?
- [Glo$ik] Yeah.
- You can see it, yeah there you go.
- [Louie] Who ever is the actor,
it's got to be one of these two.
- [Nizzy] You would say
that, you would say that.
- No dead ass smell my
breath, smell my breath.
(bell rings)
- Everybody step back I don't
want anyone to not like me.
- Is that good?
Okay.
- This is my vote.
- Like I can't trust him, you know?
Oh yeah dude, the British
guy was for sure the mole.
Just because I can't trust non-Americans.
Not because he's not American,
but because he is not American.
(upbeat music)
- Really?
- [Nizzy] Goodbye.
- Really, damn.
- [Nizzy] I'm sorry.
- Can I at least prove that I was buzzing.
- [Glo$ik] Wait, you
brought a breathalyzer,
lets blow it.
- Can I show it.
- Oh okay.
Dead ass I was buzzing.
You (beep) cut me but I was buzzing.
- [Glo$ik] I don't how to read those.
- You know we're at Walmart BevMo.
We're probably the best brand out there.
I know you would probably be like,
okay this is the best seltzer on earth.
- [Hemal] Do you guys know the
she sells sea shells by the,
sea?
- [Nizzy] By the sea shore.
Sally sells sea shells.
- Okay you go first.
- [Kelly] What?
(all simultaneously
says the tongue twister)
- Wait but not even
sober people can do that.
Hey, let's do something way more cool.
We're gonna place spin the bottle.
If you don't make out with the
person you're (beep) sober.
So my idea is that like
if you can kiss someone when you're drunk
you're definitely drunk.
Because if there's any
hesitation you can pick up on it.
All right you.
- I have to spin it.
- [Glo$ik] Yeah, you have to spin it.
Go go go.
- [Bryce] Okay I'm gonna spin it now.
Oh god, okay.
(all cheering)
- [Glo$ik] Make out with each other!
- [Jenn] Kiss kiss kiss kiss.
(all talking excitedly)
- [Glo$ik] Are you (beep) serious lets go.
Lets go.
- You guys decide.
- Oh, just a little peck.
- [Bryce] Let's do it to
prove that we're drunk.
- [Glo$ik] Yeah, yeah.
- [Bryce] How about that?
- Okay, ready?
- Here we go.
- [Hemal] Oh no, I was
going for the cheek.
He was going for my lips.
- [Bryce] Okay we can do cheek.
So you want to kiss on the cheek,
and lets get it over
with and lets move on.
- Wow they kissed on the cheek
- [Glo$ik] I love this game it's so cool.
- Okay, I think I kissed boy,
which you know, it's fine.
We kissed and then it
proved that we were good.
(Bryce and Nizzy squealing)
- [Ragini] Okay guys one second.
- [Glo$ik] Wait, it's over?
- [Ragini] No, we don't hear anything.
So many people can't talk at once.
One or two people at a time.
Otherwise we can't use
any of this footage.
- Guys we have to be responsible.
- We have to go quick.
- [Glo$ik] What is your go to dance move,
every one 5 seconds.
Wait we have, yes 5 seconds.
- [Nizzy] We have 2 minutes.
- Drunk dance moves.
- Dance moves in a line, you start.
- [Glo$ik] Your go to drunk dance moves.
- You want see the real..
Give me a beat.
(beat boxing)
(everyone screaming and cheering)
- She was really trying.
How would she be able to do that.
- What was the girl who did the splits?
What?
Ken?
Kenny?
Kelly? Kelly.
Gosh, when she did the
splits, I was like, yeah
no sober person would do the
splits right here right now.
- [Glo$ik] I wanna see you try.
- [Multiple] 5, 6, 7, 8.
(beat boxing)
- [Hemal] I wouldn't like be able to.
- That's all I got.
- Wait that was it?
- That was it.
- That was such a Trader Joe's dance.
- [Jenn] Dance.
- Okay I can only like crunk battle.
Who wants to crunk with me.
- [Bryce] I don't know what that means.
- [Nizzy] Crunk you know,
okay give me a beat.
(drunken beat boxing)
Man, if you guys could
just cut out the crunking.
that would just make my day.
(bell dings)
- [Bryce] Do we have have music here.
- [Women] 5, 6, 7, 8.
- I'm just going to clap with you guys.
- [Jenn] What?
- [Glo$ik] Oh he's sober.
(all talking and laughing)
- To be honest you should have danced.
Can you tell me his name?
The British guy.
Okay I think it's the British guy.
He seems the most coherent.
The rest of us were spilling stuff.
- [Multiple] Your turn, your turn.
- [Glo$ik] No but I
don't know how to dance.
- [Multiple] 5, 6, 7, 8.
- All I Know how to do is
just dance in morse code.
I just back it up on some dude.
(beeping in morse code)
- [Bryce] What is this World War 2?
- Bop bop, morse code.
That means D T F.
That's how you do it in morse code baby.
(bell ringing)
- Writing English is
kind of hard right now.
I'm a psychology major.
And I thought that she was playing
up that she was drunk and being silly.
- Oh
- Who the (beep) voted me?
- Okay honestly, I
don't know who voted me?
But it's honestly not me because
if I was sober, could I do this?
- [All] Yeah.
- [Hemal] That's the point.
- Who do I think it is?
Who's the mole
I think we already voted him out.
- Okay.
So I had, look
I had about a couple of
shots of tequila beforehand.
I had some tequila here.
I am drunk and I just feel
like someone is trying
to pass the buck to me.
- [Kelly] Oh semi circle, okay.
- [Nizzy] I think she's.
- [Bryce] Let's get her out of here.
Lets make some freaking money okay.
- [Jenn] Let's make some money
- [Bryce] We're on the same page.
Everybody hand in the middle.
Okay that's what I like to see.
Okay. Ready?
3, 2, 1.
Let's go.
(suspenseful percussive music)
- I really thought I was
gonna win that money.
Oh my god.
Maybe I was so drunk
that people thought
that I was acting drunk.
- Another commercial great.
- Wait Ragini you
directed this didn't you?
- I did.
- Oh my god It's so good and funny.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah. What was it like
to direct these people
- Ummm
- [Ragini] Guys no ganging up guys.
Not talking at the back.
Can you please be quiet?
It was quite a task.
I so wish even I was drunk for it.
- Oh yeah?
- By the way, your glasses
look so nice on you.
- Oh my god thank you.
They're actually from
today's sponsor Warby Parker
Warby Parker is committed
to providing exceptional vision
care online and in stores.
Offering eyeglasses, sunglasses,
eye exams and contact lenses.
- Their glasses start at $95
including prescription lenses.
Plus they've got sunglasses, progressives
and blue light lenses available too.
- [Milky] What I especially
like about Warby Parker is how
easy it is to find the
right pair of glasses.
After answering just
a few questions online
Warby Parker will suggest
glasses that fit your face
and style.
- [Ragini] Try Warby Parker's
free home try on program.
Order five pairs of glasses to try at home
for free for five days.
And there's no obligation to buy.
Ships free and includes a
prepaid return shipping label.
- Try five pairs of glasses at home
for free at warbyparker.com/jubilee.
Now let's continue the video.
- [Jenn] Sponsorship, boy
- [Hemal] I think we're good.
- [Bryce] No we're good.
- I raised my hand too.
And then I think the person
next to me raised their hand
but no one else raised their hand
and everyone's like, oh yeah,
I think we got the mole out
but I don't think we did.
- Are we voting right now?
- [Nizzy] We just did.
- Oh my god.
(suspenseful music)
- [Nizzy] So nervous.
No!
I told you, I knew it.
It's you I knew it.
Re do, re do.
- Lights turn red it was Hemal.
I knew it.
I knew we didn't get it out.
I knew we should have done one more round
but I just trusted everyone
too much in the moment.
- [Bryce] I knew it.
- Yay. I did it.
Got you.
- I was shocked.
I was so surprised that
like, she was probably
the least, the furthest
person on my radar.
- I knew it!
- [Louie] Wait but how
sober were you from 1 to 10?
- [Kelly] I am a 0 out of 10.
- I was so shocked because she
and I were kind of talking outside before
and she was drinking out
of a bottle and I was like,
okay, so she's drunk with me.
But she must have been drinking water
or pretending to sip or something.
- [Kelly] I used to be a
degenerate and now I don't drink.
So I just go out and
have fun and act drunk.
And that's how I did it.
Just takes time to really
like, love yourself
and gain that confidence
wherever you're at to know.
I don't need something to be myself
and be as fun as I wanna be.
Like, I can just do it sober.
- [Kelly] Sorry.
- [Bryce] We're stepping out.
I hope Cody Ko reviews this video.
- [Woman] Is there a possibility
that if we sniff each other
that one person might
smell really different.
- Now I'm like, I hope I smell good.
- I'm a Satanist.
- I am a Satanist.
- Yay.
(all clapping and cheering)